do you like my haircut it skis beautiful
yeah it's gorgeous I am going Swedish
the Swedish haircut okay you know the
only Swedish words I learned from like
cry of fear it's like a rock evening
forbid Juden or something like that
oh yeah or whatever okay then how am I
gonna get up there hang on Thanks
don't even try don't even try just go
hurry you're too fat you know what you
don't need to be skinny to do this sorry
Fox already my lazy the one hit around
one ah
why are four members of our team minks
mixed up like right here I know so it is
hardly fixed the mole they overlook all
four of them about oh yeah
no air strike or whatever you couldn't
hit one of us yeah you're gonna man
couldn't hit a single one of us we could
maybe around that today you couldn't do
damage to my black ass what are you
going what is it he's gonna kill us you
still get to [ __ ] play are you cereal
not it's added you got it madam that is
that is not okay what is wrong with you
you damaged your teammate I'm damaged
you baby oh [ __ ] markiplier is gonna
kick your ass no to kill pain oh you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] die well well how
do I go mark give me tip Oh kill me
yeah I want it BAE well bat I want him
together fire
just for me look look at my worm he's
crying are you crying yeah breathe oh
look at it look at the size of it oh my
God my mom rec is doing on her okay you
know oh that will look distract him long
enough so you run out of time oh it was
no hard feelings
hahaha oh look at that all boys and
everyone's gonna comment on the video
hey punkin Buster's run Oh
or you can do that this is hardly fair
why hurt our guys grouped up cuz I did
the water blasts I need know they were
grouped up before
you suck I'm just adding those groups
anger what are you doing don't touch
yourself
I mean Ming samoon what we're fine we're
fine we're fine I'm fine
don't whine I'm not makes you kill
yourself no no whoa
I feel like a plane I'm going to seek
glorious revenge mmm I like the song
down mm-hmm I'm going to well I actually
don't know what I'm gonna do and tell me
why I'm going to mmm get this sick
grenade shot here what don't do anything
stupid gonna be good
I said hush I got what Hasbun again
I didn't do well who's up oh I'm up Hey
Oh God
I don't even know what to do now uh I
think you should check out his towel
yeah please yeah yeah let's do it let's
check out his channel what do you make
on your channel these days um minecraft
and um I V log like three times a day
it's awesome you've watched it I don't
like my crib though well I mean what
about V logs yeah my blog I talk about
like my day and my dad hey wait you say
a little bit a little bit louder I talk
about my minecraft talk to the
microphone oh those titties I get a bit
burn wait is that miner dude oh no what
you guys know we're not doing well being
alright yes so two can play that game
mother talk and play their blood a game
you guys like bubbles like using it you
can be good for tomorrow
yeah my socks all right bubbles I don't
want this many bubbles over
skeet games it turns out oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I said I don't want to be this why stop
flying forgot
wasting time here okay good night hold
up guys like moles okay so you're coming
for you good yes oh why does it my not
explode huh that's it bad
yeah who's the dud I like that a dud was
a dud
so the night Fletch oh mama what oh oh
no no no yeah name is more flashy like a
plan oh do it don't do it you don't want
to touch you Swedish girls don't know
you know what it's not was it
we're gonna hold this dynamite together
oh yeah we're gonna hold it a single
tail run down my cheek
alright the fuse you're gonna run away
oh wow going awfully ma you know what
that fin 101
what are those because I know yeah
that's what I'm gonna do two can play at
this game so you can play the bottom
three yes three what I don't know why my
game is running it like 2 frames per
second but you guys are gonna get it
remember you're the fast everybody is
bad then I really a wet woman every man
what that's a nice kill myself I keep
telling you you're fat you can't do [ __ ]
like that oh I try oh that was fantastic
shut up now what a thing is amazing I
know shut what way on the same T don't
go Oh what do I want to do uh I'm gonna
try grenade shot yeah good luck with
that
you don't have the skills I got it don't
even try bro
I could do it I could do it oh wow yeah
yeah sure yeah sure yeah wow man you
totally hit that health pack that's
really cool
good job sorry this meant to you you
guys might still win this I don't see
how yeah no no you got this I believe in
you it's the real cry how do I had a
write about how to write a how to hold
her you guys throw yourself dynamite no
I think he uses up oh you don't want you
know this you can do this you use your
rape skills come on hurry up
Oh what are you doing woman oh oh one
one I was there
physics doesn't work broken game
unsubscribe everyone is dead on that
side by the way Buster's on that wall is
dead don't jump jump jump jump jump
gromek shift see what happens Jim is
it's the win button John oh god you're
fat man oh that's pretty nice for
grouping up mmm I'm really sorry if we
leave what hey oh my hair do something
I'm gonna do that battery no yeah by a
grandma head why I'm really good oh oh
oh
alcohol oh oh oh good night
oh I don't obviously uh what everything
wait no that's a fish fat Souls gotta
come down Myrtle's gonna don't you keep
forgetting you're a fat man dude oh no
oh oh oh
and what was it that back on every 100
you line into water nice Wow good job
mark
they're turning things around minx I
have 10 things around they're gonna win
the good people health ones we just
don't touch cry don't cry team cries -
Pro to be beaten by you can I will never
die even though Christ already dead in
the last episode I know caption oh no
the option sound really close to him and
shoot it works really well
stay close yes yeah
are you sure do that yeah how close like
really close
tell me straight three centimeters if
you're gonna shoot someone you got to
look at the only show down shoot wait
wait up wait up
we're beautiful what ya did hurt me yeah
what's the hum oh this is really bad
he's gonna kill the show I have a better
the plant than you and your bullshit's
okay hmm
oh no he's going for the help whoa gonna
win they're gonna win up makes we got to
get things together here it's going
three help you guys like games wait how
do i how do i how - Jota Jota hata okay
I thought you had a plan really shut
shush
why'd you go through here just get his
jet pack down I've got a weapon if
you're gonna get something it's right up
there way way Mike a plane house gonna
kill him [ __ ] yeah trouble you alright I
would wanna kill him hahaha
we're not in trouble I sense there's a
way out of this I'm not really sure what
the way out is but there is a way out
there's nearly bring it on I don't think
I can really do I do I do have something
I can you don't try hard
Wow sorry really what is not gonna do
yeah what are they gonna do it nothing
he has a microphone elixir do you like
it okay
is my microphone did you just do that
now oh yeah good oh there goes mass
difference
what there goes mass scammer that's it
you know what Shh
oh this is mother I guess unlock spread
100 guys fast walk inhaling down go
markiplier I'm gonna you sons of asses
God okay last thing ever
ah you could have won it here oh oh now
you do nice
well well if you can't kill them all the
time don't kill your tall yeah that
didn't bite I'm all right
oh you can buy stuff um you don't want
to buy anything um um you want a new
haircut that's what you want yeah yeah
yeah yeah don't touch cray
yeah touch me I think touch me hard
touch sham touch me touch me do it I'm
right yeah let's mark out the game it's
just Gandalf versus on bring it on [ __ ]
you have three cakes well I just call
you Gandalf now rich haha you can do it
I believe though you're like nothing I
do like nothing yes
let's go that oh I'll have all the
nothing salad oh ah [ __ ]
you can do a new looks whoa that's what
Jesus is that you may be the life
Mike Ryan what do I do tell me how do I
win this pile of fruit but that's all
what will happen when I know will it
heart along will you be there
but that didn't hurt less what I don't
understand your ways what what what are
you what are you what are you talking
about what it was is I was just you know
well you just jump off the edge
why don't you stop telling me what to do
yeah jeez let me play his game alright
how do I use the parachute ah it feels
so
uh all right if you get in between them
and shotgun them you can get one yeah
there you go you got it you got it is he
gonna waste it
do it why you know tell me is exploding
okay next time you tell me properly in
time okay
get Damon market play um you could be in
trouble here but my gosh all me suspect
me
oh I didn't damn it know what it's fine
it's all part on the plane oh yeah I'll
play I have many plans what is the plan
it looks you think I'm gonna tell you
the plan can you tell me the plan cuz I
would like to know go in Jesus formula
will do it oh no mark ariados oh honey I
need your wisdom I don't have a plan you
freaking father I don't have any plan I
know he's not you
that's not the rock is not know you're
the other one oh you don't want to do
that oh are you boy
no we're about now that's not gonna kill
me oh it doesn't matter I fought you off
for a few seconds long
Oh [ __ ] why are you not dead
yeah that was down to one I know and
mono by the fogger uh if I had killed um
with that mortar strike yeah you're
right we would have won god damn it that
was something so close yeah ah you
should have went in Jesus moaning this I
know well I think yeah I'll be a man be
a man be a man
what uh y-yeah okay I know right
everyone I have to piss everyone on
YouTube
oh my case seriously
Crick you can decide okay don't worry
about me man uh uh
now cows no no no oh I wasn't trying to
kill you I just wanted to make it fun
no no cows anything with the cows me a
man be a man what is oh okay now Felix
come on just please I'm begging you
don't mess up like this did you just
kill him do what everything's okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay
two can play this game oh god yes
straight okay what do I do
okay no you what do I know
what do I do anything right hope they'll
be entertaining Manny
yeah air strikes can you buy something I
can buy a grandma oh that one's older
everyone can buy a grandma he can
teleport yeah you can tell up to where
mom is
I don't care what it is yeah no he'll
kill you before you get there
uh you can't she hit him with a rocket I
reckon through the walls might I might
have I don't know what that was for god
damn okay all right teleport and get
that supply crate home you don't know
what you're doing be a man come on damn
man how many baby such like a cheating
[ __ ]
Oh God poor sport ohmwrecker and now he
fell right in my train wait Felix do you
have a bunker-buster
what's that well I think it's like a
dream straight down
oopsie hey see ya bill man yeah yeah
yeah penalty of manliness
Oh low in the ninth best game ever ten
out of ten best game I've ever played in
my entire life
you guys are scrubs look at how sad
firms are look what you did to us
I feel no regret be a mane yeah those
those beautiful this beautiful ooh hey
let's just suck I mean not honestly my
one has worms that's how it is
ah yeah you should have that looked up
to you sky
you can infect other people you know
that right okay bye okay that's cute
like you guys that was fun
see ya hey guys
all my neighbors are listening to this I
got Namek follow me winning jackpot